si vous deviez me fait râler un top 3
des présentateurs de jt et les trois
meilleurs et celui que vous trouvez un
petit peu le moins bon à l'e3 mais
heureusement mon allergie le premier
pernaut indiscutablement c'est celui qui
colle aux français c'est le meilleur
deuxième je pense que je mettrais gilles
bouleau d'accord et 3e je vous dis très
franchement j'ai du mal
je n'aime pas delahousse mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il a le mérite de tenir
là aussi tu veux tu peux ressortir des
vies tellement c'était beau mais depuis
jaras a bien sûr tant les idées mais il
est encore dans la course les de
vernouillet sur lci habana commun
combien de pernod deuxième pujadas et un
troisième
voilà boulot je pense notamment mathieu
mathieu et alors je te dire pujadas
lapix boulot mais surtout père dont je
n'ai pas en numéro 1 au mois pernaut
pardon de dire c'est pas un animateur de
jt il anima magazine à 13h30 dans lequel
il met ce qu'il veut c'est un magazine
mais les régions et tout ça mais c'est
pas un animateur de gîte écolo sans son
lancement il apporte plus il apporte
méfaits magazine de ifa magazine de
requins
voilà il fait un magazine sur tf1 il
fait pas un jt et d'ailleurs comment
aller pour moi ils apportent ils
apportent beaucoup plus que tous les
autres après bon voila vous faites ce
que vous voulez gilles je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec mathieu je trouve
qu'il a une vision très bobo très
parisienne bourgeoise de dire que
pernaut ne fait pas agité il fait le jt
de la vie quotidienne des français bien
sûr ses meilleurs des jt c'est le seul
que tous les gens regardent
regardez vous en parlait récemment y
suivent quasiment ses prédictions ses
indications
c'est celui qui sent le plus la france
donc c'est un présentateur de jt bien
sûr